NEXT SATURDAY NIGHT.
SAME PLACE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I JUST SAID HOW
LONG HAVE YOU TWO BEEN TOGETHER?
HE MET HER AT THE RALLY IN
COLORADO.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
MAN, DID HE GET LUCKY.
GREG: HE’S NOT JUST A PRESIDENT.
HE’S A MATCHMAKER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: WAS THAT A DEBATE PORE
WHAT?
HERE IS MY FAVORITE MOMENT.
THERE IS BLOOMBERG UNDER THERE
SOMEWHERE.
FIRST THERE IS MINI MIKE.
NO BOXES.
WE CALL HIM NO BOXES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: MINI MIKE.
NO BOXES.
WE CALL HIM NO BOXES.
AND I HEAR HE’S GETTING POUNDS
TONIGHT.
HE’S IN A DEBATE.
I HEAR THEY ARE POUNDING HIM.
GREG: HE GOT POUNDED LIKE A
DANDELION IN A HAILSTORM.
>> A MAN WHO CALLS WOMEN FAT
BROADS AND HORSE FACED LESS
BIANS.
>> HE ASK ASK STOP AND FRISKS
AND THROWS 5 MILLION BLACK MEN
UP AGAINST A WALL.
>> HALF A MILLION PEOPLE SLEEP
SHOUT ON THE STREET TONIGHT.
>> WE HAVE A VERY FEW
NON-DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS.
>> HOW MANY IS THIS?
GREG: HE SHOULD HAVE SAID ONLY
ROSIE O’DONNELL.
HE GOT PASSED AROUND LIKE A
PORNO IN A FRAT HOUSE.
HE DID SO BAD YOU.
BLOOK BLOOMBERG MADE A FOOL OUT
OF HIMSELF THAT NIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: BLOOMBERG MADE
A FOOL OUT OF HIMSELF LAST
NIGHT.
HE SAID I CAN’T BREATHE, I CAN’T
BREATHE.
DON’T ASK ME A QUESTION.
GREG: YOU HAVE GOT TO HAND IT TO
POCAHONTAS.
SHE TOOK BLOOMBERG POUT.
MAIN SHE IS PART NATIVE AMERICAN
BECAUSE THAT FELT LIKE LITTLE
BIG HORN.
THEN THERE IS JOE.
AKA JAN BRADY.
INSTANTLY BECOMES FORGOTTEN WHEN
SOME OTHER PEOPLE ARE IN THE
ROOM.
HE IS THE CAN DIP D HE IS THE CA
HALLOWEEN THAT NOBODY EATS.
THE GOOD AND PLENTIES.
THE NERKS CCO WAFERS.
>> THE HISTORY IS FULL OF GREAT
COMEBACKS.
ALEXANDER HAMILTON, HE HAD A
ROUGH TIME IN THAT DUEL, BUT HE
LIVED TO TALK ABOUT IT.
JACK DAWSON WENT DOWN WITH THE
TITANIC.
BUT LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM.
LIVED A LONG LIFE AND BECAME
KING OF FRANCE.
OLD YELLER FOUGHT THAT.
WOLF AND GOT RAINIES.
THE MULLET IS COMING BACK.
BUSINESS UP FRONT, PARTY IN MY
PANTS.
GREG: JOE WAS LUCKY BEING
FORGOTTEN STANDING ON THE STAGE.
HE WAS ALREADY DEAD, HE JUST
DIDN’T KNOW IT.
SO WHY KICK HIM, LET’S ASK HIM.
>> JOE BIDEN ON MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG.
>> YOU CAN’T BUY AN ELECTION.
I KNOW I TRIED.
I HAVE BEEN TO ALL THE SITES.
QVC, ETSY.
HOT TOPIC.
NO ELECTIONS ON SALE THERE.
I EVEN TRIED THAT AMAZON.
YEAH.
GOT LOST IN THE RAIN FOREST
CAFE.
GREAT BEEF NACHOS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO WONDER HOW THEY
GET THAT COW TO THE TOP OF THE
VOLCANO.
TEXT JOE TO JOE VERSUS THE VAL
KAY --VOLCANO.
GREG: THEN THERE WAIST WAS AMY.
THE GUNFIGHT AT THE GLEE CLUB.
>> YOU HAVE NOT WENT IN ARENA
DOING THAT WORK.
YOU MEMORIZE A BUNCH OF TALKING
POINTS.
GREG: OH, WOW.
MAYOR PETE IS THAT ANNOYING GUY
ON TRIVIA NIGHT HOP TELLS
EVERYONE HIS I.Q. BUT HE STILL
LOSE.
THEN BERNIE.
WHEN A CAPITALIST AND SOCIALIST
ARE ON THE SAME STAGE AND THE
CAPITALLIVE GETS THROWN UNDER
IT.
ISN’T THAT WHAT SOCIALISM IS?
IT’S NOT ABOUT SPREADING WEALTH,
BUT BY SPREADING ENVY OF WHICH
BERNIE HAS AN ENDLESS SUPPLY.
BUT BERNIE WON THE DEBATE
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WENT FOR THE
BILLIONAIRE.
BERNIE IS THE SCRAWNIEST CHING
IN THE BUCKET.
EVERYONE GETS EATEN BEFORE HIM.
I-THINK IT’S FOWL.
DON’T CLAP FOR THAT.
THAT’S TERRIBLE.
SO THE DEBATE BECAME A LIFE BOAT
THAT’S SEATS ONLY FIVE BUT 60s
WANTED --BUT SIX WANTED IN.
BLOOMBERG WAS THE ON SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSMAN THERE.
HE EMPLOYED THOUSANDS AND MADE
BILLIONS.
NO LONGER A SUCCESS STORY, HE’S
ONLY A WHITE SEXIST MALE, SO
SKIN HIM ALIVE, BOYS.
IMAGINE IF TRUMP WAS UP THERE
INSTEAD OF MINI MIKE.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN PERCEIVE
GENIUS BY ITS ABSENCE.
AND WHAT IS MISSION IS WHAT
TRUMP POSSESSES.
I THINK THE DEMS KNOW THAT BY
NOW.
>> I WANT TO --
GREG: WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?
WHY IS IT THAT LEFT WING
PROTESTERS ALWAYS SOUNDS LIKE
POLTERGEISTS.
IT’S LIKE A SCREECHING GHOUL YOU
CONJURE UP AT A A SEANCE WITH A
QIJII BOARD.
NO WONDER THE MEDIA REACTED THIS
WAY.
>> BLOOMBERG WAS AWFUL.
>> THEY AGREEN BERNIE IS THE
LEADER.
IF SOMETHING DOESN’T STOP HIM.
>> THIS WAS A DISASTER.
>> IT WAS A GREAT NIGHT FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE NIGHT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
IF BERNIE IS ALLOWED TO WIN IT
THEY WILL BE IN MORE TROUBLE
THAN THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE IN.
>> I DON’T SEE HIM HAVING ANY
SHOT IN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
I’M PANICKED.
GREG: I’M SO HAPPY HE’S
PANICKED.
I FOR ONE CAN’T WAIT FOR THE
NEXT WEEK’S DEBATE.
IT’S TUESDAY.
HERE IS THE PREVIEW.